Alex Jones sat with the January 6 panel
and repeatedly pleaded the fifth then he
revealed what they asked him on his
broadcast so this is politico's Congress
minutes and they actually break down a
bit of what Alex Jones has said they say
here's the rundown of from Jones who
called the committee's questions overall
pretty reasonable some of these things
are very interesting
Jones said the January 6 committee
seemed to have a lot of detailed
information about him that that they
displayed images of text messages he had
with Ren and Cindy chefian
who organized a pro-trump rally on
January 5th both Ren and chaffian had
been subpoenaed by the committee last
fall
Jones said he started to have doubts
about leading a March to the capital
when he saw the unwieldy crowd that
informed at Trump's ellipse speech quote
you know maybe we just won't do what he
said
he said he thought to himself he said he
continued however when Secret Service
agents came and opened up the gate after
he arrived at the Capitol and witnessed
some of the ongoing Mayhem Jones was
seen on video repeatedly attempting to
steer the crowd away from police Lines
no no Politico you need to be more
direct and more honest than that Alex
Jones is on video telling people to
avoid the capital and not to go in
because it's a trick and it's a trap and
so they want you to do Jones was
actively bullhorning to de-escalate and
get people away from the capital that
would be very important to include but
they did not Jones said the committee
asked about his contacts with proud boys
he said that he added a Hooters in
Atlanta with some members he said he
didn't use proud boys or Oath Keepers as
security he was a prominent company he
said that January 6 he relied on a
prominent austin-based security firm he
said the committee suggested they
routinely monitor his show he denied
being aware of a January uh I'm sorry of
a December 31st broadcast in which his
substitute host Matthew Bracken
specifically suggested storming the
capital wow that's crazy Jones also
acknowledged that his Co co-host Owen
Shroyer who has been charged for egging
on the crowd in the restricted area of
the capital was facing prosecution Jones
said the charges were for a bunch of
stuff he didn't do and he falsely said
Troyer is facing years in prison I think
it's fair to say incorrectly falsely
kind of implies he was intentionally
wrong the misdemeanor charge against
Shroyer Kerry a maximum six-month
sentence so I'll tell you right away the
crazy thing about this is that they've
got his texts that that's creepy but
obvious right the government's got your
private information they know what you
do on your phone in your private time
and if you're not using a VPN and you're
not using a signal for encrypted stuff
just you know Adam Schiff he knows
everything you know what's funny I'm
sorry real quick just Mark Zuckerberg
knows when you poop yep I'm willing to
bet for a lot of you guys out there Adam
Schiff knows when you poop too oh gosh
and he's gonna tell Nicole Wallace about
it too oh yeah he's gonna go on MSNBC
he'll link to his uh link to his friends
at the Washington Post in the New York
Times you know there's there's no end
for Adam Schiff here he's going to hold
up an envelope and be like I have
documents about what time Alex Jones was
pooping I think one of the things that
bothers me here is um
okay you hear this like they can spy on
you they can read your text messages
they have total oversight control I hear
that a lot it's not until it becomes
personal and it actually happens to you
that it's like whoa Sound the Alarm this
isn't right yeah you have this happen
with crime in major cities right now you
have CNN questioning whether that
actually is happening Brian stelter did
a segment on a show on Sunday it's very
similar in that that they'll mock the
media Will Mock anything and everything
that's happening to everyone else in the
country because it's not happening to
them right they feel safe in their homes
they feel like their privacy is being
protected
until something happens to them and then
it then it's all that's often you would
think they would change their minds but
in many cases it doesn't do you see
that's a story from Sanjay Gupta where
he wrote about going on Joe Rogan's
podcast and he said that he was scared
that Joe was going to jump the table and
throttle his neck right he goes in with
these incredibly unreasonable
expectations it's probably because it's
what Jeff Zucker and Jake Tapper and
Brian stelter told him is gonna happen
they painted this caricature and this
goes to the larger point of anybody who
doesn't you know toe the line is part of
that corporate machine they think you're
this crazy person and they view us like
zoo animals almost that we can just they
can tap on the glass almost our friend
Sheamus over at Freedom Tunes made it
one of the funniest videos I've ever
done is about the Joe Rogan Sanjay Gupta
thing and he just plays some audio of
Joe Rogan talking and he's like don't
you think it's dangerous when a media
company lies and then it just so shows
Sanjay Gupta going
but then but then it then he's then it
shows you know Joe again and he goes
don't then then he specifically mentions
CNN this massive Media company and then
it shows this fake like CNN with two
anchors screaming and crying like
and it's like it says in the Chiron Joe
Rogan attacks media yeah that's that's
what that's literally what it is right
and and this is the problem that we've
had for the last however many years
which is people would say at a trump
rally you suck and guess what it's
treated like a death threat you know the
First Amendment they believe only
applies to them not the rest the rest of
us because it's too dangerous for anyone
else to have speech this is the crazy
thing about Alex Jones I'm gonna say
that one of the most I'm gonna trigger
The Establishment press oh boy I'm going
to trigger all of the left with the
following
four words
Alex Jones I'm sorry is it technically
five because of the a Alex Jones is a
journalist
I remember a few years ago I said that
Infowars was kind of like a right-wing
Huffington Post but it was it was in a
specific context where I was saying that
in the election cycle you know with
Donald Trump Infowars was trying very
much to be more mainstream and to speak
to the Maga crowd and that as The
Huffington Post does that for you know
liberals Alex Jones was very much trying
to do that with infowars.com so whether
you agree with Alex Jones his political
positions his opinions whether you
believe him to be telling the truth or
not is not relevant to the fact that he
isn't he is he is a dude who collects
and disseminates information I gotta be
honest I think sometimes he says really
crazy things yeah I think I'm sorry I'm
sorry I'm in Austin yeah yeah absolutely
but the the reason I say he's a
journalist is because he's afforded the
same protections as any other member of
the press and while my opinion of it may
be like he's a pundit he's a personality
on paper legally there should be no
distinction between him Don Lemon or
James Rosen these are people who are
speaking in the public about public
policy and politics the problem is these
people at CNN on these other other
outlets they they they basically gloat
and laugh and mock Alex while he's
getting his private text messages taken
by the I mean this this should be
a Fourth Amendment violation right
exactly and I think you know they've
done they've been obsessing about this
all afternoon since it came out that he
testified before the committee five
MSNBC shows and four CNN shows have
spent time talking about this versus
really anything else that's going on in
the world of really gloating about how
many times he took the fifth and it just
shows what a Croc also that this entire
committee is you can remove Alex Jones
and replace him with really anyone
that's going before this committee and
you and as you point out you don't even
have to like Alex Jones a lot he says a
lot of crazy things and uh it's pretty
horrible some of the things that he said
in my opinion but it just this story in
particular just shows what a Croc this
entire thing is and how it's really
something for the benefit of CNN and
msnbc's green room oh definitely you
know since Trump left their ratings are
in the gutter and I think
any honest any look I'll say this of
Brian stelter he deserves and and should
be afforded his right to speak and if
CNN wants to spend money to have this
guy on the air to espouse his message
you're allowed to do it there are a lot
of people that I think are very very
evil they put out fake news they lied
they cheat they manipulate and I'm sure
a lot of people feel that way about Alex
Jones now for all the crazy things Alex
has said it's kind of scary when he gets
things right and they're really weird
things he gets right like when he told
me about how we eat cloned beef and I'm
like Alex they're not cloning cows and
he was like Tim look it up and then I
Googled it and right there on the show
I'm like he's right
so it's like he knows his weird stuff
that nobody believes and so my issue my
thing is it's just you know I try to
look at this as neutrally as possible
the government has the private text
messages of a media personality they
didn't they didn't file subpoena against
him to get it they went straight to the
phone companies and said can we have it
and the phone companies just went yup so
this is deeply troubling to me because I
think that at an underlying level people
it's because they're so smug about it
because they assume that it will never
ever happen to them I know that they're
wrong I know that the tables can turn
but they don't think it ever will and
I'm not convinced that with the Turning
of the political tide it won't be them
on the table they don't want to set this
precedent but they're just gloating in
it right now because they're so
incredibly short-sighted they cannot
think past stage one it's ridiculous
yeah and the entire January 6 committee
is they're again as their golden calf
they are obsessed with it right for the
anniversary CNN MSNBC spent over 1600
minutes in one day talking about the
first anniversary of January 6th first
anniversary you know is it a candlelight
vigil right and they had they had you
know A Chorus on the steps of the
Capitol that sang songs they had this
prayer service and all this stuff I mean
it so anything January 6th they're gonna
drop it doesn't matter what's going on
in the world right now you know we weeks
months down the road you know we could
be in wars on two different fronts and
if something happens with January 6th
they're going to be like okay hold on we
got something I think they're realizing
though I mean I think the Democratic
establishment is is stuck and there's
nothing they can do because they've just
they've they've made it their their
whole you know like the whole party
message but when you see like Barry
Weiss on Bill Maher and they're all of a
sudden just saying like right wing
tribal talking points I'm just like ah
here it is here we go they're jumping
off the ship they know it's sinking
they're realizing what's going on I do
want to point out that was really funny
a second ago when we were when I
mentioned the the candlelight vigil and
then sucking Ian's face just went like
he had the strange looking So Hunger
Games dude
do they have big wigs on and a bunch of
makeup they were all wearing like black
and holding candles Ian's face was like
and then in CNN set up this like stature
in Statuary Hall they set up this like
you know race stage in the middle uh for
their like two hour Prime Time event
with Jake Tapper and Anderson Cooper to
speak in hush tones of course yes I mean
it's like we're just checking the boxes
here if I was playing a game of like
Civilization and I was the leader of
this country it that would be like use
propaganda if you chose to do that you'd
pick like some little thing and make a
big production out of it over and over
again and you're just trying to
manipulate and hope they don't figure
out that you're trying to manipulate
them we got we got social media these
days you know uh if this was 30 years
ago Alex Jones is not a guy they'd want
to put on TV they wouldn't want to give
him a chance to actually defend himself
or speak up they you know and they don't
I mean these mainstream media companies
they don't want them on they they want
to be able to to control the narrative
they want to keep all these Democrats
wrapped up in their bubble in this cult
believing whatever it is they say and
they live in this crazy world where they
think Alex Jones is this evil Boogeyman
or people like James O'Keefe the first
time I met Alex Jones uh when we came on
the show he told me he's like he saw one
of my videos where like Alex went to the
grocery store and people were screaming
at him and then I was just like that's
so insane dude to like see this guy
buying milk can just start screaming at
him and Alex is probably like I'm just
buying milk you know but Alex was like
that's exactly what it is like I don't
even know who you are like leave me
alone I'm just buying milk man and you
see how much that's grown with people
being harassed in public places you know
and not just Alex Jones now yeah you see
that video we talked about the other day
where these this is just black dude gets
in an elevator and these two white
liberal women go in and they're
screaming at him to get out because he's
not wearing a mask and they're filming
each other like then the women hit the
black dude and then he's like you hit me
and then she goes black lives matter
right black lives matter what dude we're
losing our minds man right that's why
yes Libs of tick tock might be one of my
favorite accounts on all of social media
it is endless laughs yeah so while
you're you know at NewsBusters and
you're tracking the mainstream corporate
press you got Libs of tick tock on
Twitter tracking Tick Tock posting all
of that absolute and Sandy
I gotta say though if you're not
familiar with Libs of tick tock
definitely follow them on Twitter
because well
it is confirmation bias it is
politically affirming but I also want to
warn this severely depressing it may
entertain you for a while but after like
the 50th video of this stuff you're just
like I think the world has ended yeah
right you can always skip remember that
yeah sweet meteor of death let's go yeah
seriously man thanks for checking out
this segment from the timcast IRL
podcast if you want to watch live you
can check out this channel Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and don't forget
to smash that like button subscribe to
this Channel and if you want more
unfiltered and uncensored content with
all of these guests go to timcast.com
and become a member all of these guests
you know and love in exclusive segments
on our website where we are unrestricted
in what we talk about so you'll
definitely not want to miss it thanks
for hanging out we'll see you all next
time